[Music]
Dalton is in Dallas Texas hi Dalton how
are you hi Dave I'm doing awesome sir
how are you better than I deserve what's
up all right so I'm getting married here
in February here in a couple months
ngratulations thank you sir
I myself am on baby steps for my fiance
is on baby step two she's got about
12,000 left to pay down on a car and so
you know before I start listening I put
some money into Employee Stock Purchase
Plan and I have kind of that as one of
my more liquid investments and her and I
are looking to get her debt paid down
once we get married and b2 to eventually
you know get ourselves into a house and
so my question for you is I've got about
8,000 bucks sitting in mindfully stock
purchase plan now is that something that
I should go ahead and pull out to get
her debt paid down to put that towards a
house or because I myself I'm already on
maybe step 4 you know should I keep that
where it's at and kind of use that as
one of my investments moving forward
okay so you have an emergency fund aside
from this right 8,000 an employee stock
purchase plan do you have any other
money that's not in a retirement account
aside from my emergency phone no sir
okay yeah I would stop doing any
investing if I were in your shoes and
start piling up cash to do two things
one are to do three things one is pay
off her debt when you come home from the
honeymoon and using the employee stock
option and any money you save up to do
that - you're probably going to raise
your emergency fund a little when the
two of you are married and you've got a
larger household income and then three
to use to start saving for your down
payment awesome so yeah stop investing
and use that when the time comes I mean
you can let it sit there that employee
stock things that there if the stocks
doing well and you want to sit on it
till February that's fine
nothing in the world but I mean it's
likely not gonna go in half unless you
work for a very very volatile company
that's right you know if you got a
pretty stable company it's doing pretty
well then yeah ride that thing out write
it and if you're worried about it just
pull it and set it in savings it's not a
problem either way
that you don't as you said and I'll
repeat what you said I don't tell you to
pay off your fiancees dead until you
return from the honeymoon and your
fiance is now your wife that's when you
pay off the debt not until but you get
all prepared to where you write those
checks and then as a couple we're on
baby step three B meaning we're have our
emergency fund in place we're debt-free
as a couple home from the honeymoon and
we've got a head start towards saving
for our home and that's maybe step three
B and you may spend that first year of
marriage on your budget saving very
aggressively for your down payment and
then after about a year of marriage or
nine months of marriage you start
shopping and thinking about buying a
house and buy the house and then of
course you're about you're on two baby
steps four and six which we don't have
children at that point so there's no
five no kids college but you'd start 15%
going into your income and start paying
off that house you bought early is maybe
step six so you're right on track to do
all of that you're thinking man you're
thinking this is going to work